my question was what was the thing that
truly pissed you off that your dad did
to you to encourage you to fight him he
took all my underwear out replaced it
with panties and they all had a day of
the week on them right so Monday Monday
through Sunday right I used to tell him
put your Mondays on dude come on out
here he was like
you the thing that oh infuriates me or
infuriated me the most he used to put a
glob of Vaseline in each one of my
hoodie Pockets my jacket pockets
sometimes my pants Pockets so I put
everything on be like all right I'm
ready to go and I put my hand in my
pocket and it was
just yo yo that pissed me off I knew
that was it yo it's 7:00 in the morning
and I'm going to school I'm already not
the happiest person in the world add
sticking my hand in petroleum jelly at
7:15 in the morning doesn't make me feel
a lot better you know